[Music]
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight if there's one thing
your average liberal understands
perfectly well it's that there's safety
in numbers don't go out alone bring 80
million people with you it's safer that
way
there is a reason a fundamental reason
that Democrats are natural joiners and
organizers and petition signers that
their highest virtue is conformity
they know that as long as they're all
wearing the same uniform they'll
probably be okay
this is why you'll see one person in
Brookline or Bethesda raise a Ukrainian
flag in the yard and the very next day
everybody on the street will have one
too
suddenly it's an entire neighborhood of
foreign policy experts all specializing
in Eastern European border disputes
it's amazing just last year these very
same people were all eminent virologists
every one of them with passionate views
on the details of pandemic management
this is in other words not a movement of
rugged individuals this is a party based
on the idea of the group the bureaucracy
The Blob it's the party of weak fearful
people who are huddled together for
Collective power
when the Democratic party speaks it is
always with one voice often in a North
Korean accent
one thing the party often speaks about
is gun control no American has the right
to own an effective firearm a firearm
that does what Firearms are supposed to
they'll tell you this at length having a
gun like that is just too much autonomy
for you if it continues you may start to
believe that you're a free Citizen and
we can't allow that and we won't Joe
Biden for instance makes this point
regularly watch
we're living in a country Awash in
weapons of war I've got it done once I'm
going to do it again eliminate assault
weapon it's time to ban these
time to ban these weapons the right to
bear arms is not an absolute right that
dominates all others you don't need an
RAR 15. I'm serious think about it ban
assault weapons in high capacity
magazines
ah you don't need an ra15 or whatever
they call it so that's the head of the
democratic party speaking very clearly
that the party's position on guns if we
don't control them you can't have them
every Democrat thinks this is part of
the catechism so you can imagine our
surprise the other day we're driving
through Cambridge in the old Hybrid
Subaru adjusting our surgical masks to
cover both nose and mouth and listening
needless to say to National Public Radio
the voice of menopausal liberalism
and as we're listening we hear this
we're going to play it for you and see
if you can understand our total shock
mass shootings targeting lgbtq spaces
and arise in anti-trans rhetoric have
inspired some queer people to take up
Arms New Hampshire's public radio Todd
Bookman joined the monthly Gathering of
a gun group that sees Firearms as key to
their own self-defense and as you might
imagine this story does include the
sound of gunfire on a recent Sunday
morning the parking lot of patakaway
State Park in Southeastern New Hampshire
is filling up with hikers there's also a
different crew packing up warm clothes
and weapons thank you all for coming to
uh rainbow reload
your anti-trans rhetoric
makes the trans Community carry guns
rainbow reload they're packing heat
they'll be appendix carrying in more
ways than one watch out wait a second we
thought
this is NPR National Public Radio
suddenly telling you that actually
guns are good they're valuable tools of
self-defense really against you
so there are times when guns or Goods
says NPR and we thought wait a second
we've been listening to NPR since well
Click and Clack the tappet brothers and
we remember very clearly their position
on guns for example quote the US has
more guns than any other country in the
world
this is the same NPR that in between
updates on the latest trans dinosaur
emojis we've been following those very
carefully routinely run segments calling
for more gun control and not subtle ones
like the segment entitled many gun
owners support gun control so why don't
they speak out oh yeah a lot a lot of
gun owners more gun control of course
they do and yet here's that same
National Public Radio
State Radio State media
controlled by the body Administration
encouraging people to go to the gun
store immediately but not all people
just trans people guns are bad except in
the hands
of trans people
wow here's more
groups like rainbow reload exist around
the country often called pink pistol
clubs it's a place for experts and the
gun curious to practice and improve
their shooting but this goes beyond
hobby there's a practical goal here to
prepare and protect themselves if the
world is dangerous then you have to be
dangerous back and that very much has
pushed me into where I am now
the gun curious well you know when NPR
describes something as they fill in the
blank curious then it's a good thing
the pedophile curious now the gun
curious the world is dangerous you have
to be dangerous back
now is that a quote from an FBI
indictment of The Proud boys no it's
from an NPR segment
at this point it's hard to tell the
difference in the lip smacking NPR
reporters just say it without any sense
of self-awareness at all
what is going on here well you know
what's going on here
is that NPR has decided that guns are
bad except when the enforces of its
ideology have guns you can't have guns
but Faithful Servants of the democratic
party can that makes sense because like
all totalitarians they want a monopoly
on Force
right so debate ends at that point when
one side has all the Firearms you don't
have to argue
you say well you can't change your sex
shut up bigot Bang Bang
[Laughter]
what's interesting is this is not just
one NPR segment the social justice
reporter from NPR station
knkx in Seattle a reporter called Lily
Anna Fowler just reported on a
fascinating story it's the suicide of a
self-described trans person called UC in
case you want to look it up it's e-u-c-y
here's how that NPR reporter described
the suicide of UC quote spoke to Rachel
a friend of UC the Ballard resident who
died by suicide yesterday while being
evicted by King County sheriff's
deputies Rachel says her friend had
tried to get help in paying rent but
exhausted all options
well that sounds awful so here's a
person who's fallen on Hard Times like
so many Americans is getting bounced out
of her apartment and kills herself out
of desperation and anyone hearing or
reading that dispatch from NPR reporter
Lily Anna Fowler would feel pretty bad
for the person who killed him or herself
politics aside completely
but it turns that NPR didn't tell the
entire story what NPR left out was that
UC had shot a sheriff's deputy prior to
killing himself
in fact Lucy put that sheriff's deputy
in the hospital where he remains tonight
after undergoing emergency surgery
that wasn't of any interest whatsoever
to NPR's social justice team they just
didn't care what they wanted you to know
was that UC was part of the trans
community and UC died
and so Lucy's life matters much more
than anyone's including the cop he shot
and certainly more than yours
so what underlies all of us it's not
about trans rights of course do you
really think Joe Biden and his faithful
vice president care about trans rights
not one bit about as much as they care
about the daily suffering in Selma
Alabama not at all
Selma Alabama is a desperate Place
poverty and violence Define it but they
show up once a year to relive the civil
rights movement and then they leave
that's how much they care and that's
precisely how much they care about the
trans Community the trans community of
course is a vehicle for something else
and it's always the same thing which is
political power and political power made
possible by political violence they want
to be able to commit it and they want
you defenseless
so you can't fight back
a lot of people in this country want it
not just NPR listeners when police are
holding a press conference about the
shooting again the shooting of a police
officer by a trans identifying
individual called UC
activists heckled the police spokeswoman
as the cop was in the hospital
undergoing emergency surgery why because
they said the spokeswoman misgendered
the shooter watch this
we've been led to believe that that your
29 year old man is actually a
transgender person is there any truth to
that I have no idea I actually knew the
person they are trans and I ask that
they don't be dead named thank you
yeah
okay so obviously this country has
reached Peak frivolity the officer is in
the hospital fighting for his life but
the debate is whether we're dead naming
someone who shot him
so the people in that frame and a lot of
people actually who listen to NPR care
more about pronouns than human life and
parrot rather you didn't know any of
this we only know that this actually
happened because reporters like Jason
Rance and Andy know one like NPR don't
take any money from taxpayers we're
paying attention and knew the details
and by the way Andy know has run the
numbers about these claims of violence
and genocide against the trans community
and here's what he found having done
actual Research into a quote there is no
genocide of trans people in the U.S or
anywhere in the West in fact there's
been an explosion of trans identifying
people which research suggests is a
social contagion spread by social media
fads and youth peer pressure the few
dozen trans people tragically killed in
America each year are usually murdered
by black men in the course of
prostitution activities
so we believe that that is factually
true
none of that ever gets mentioned of
course least of all on National Public
Radio what does get mentioned well the
neo-nazis of course they're the real
threat they're the ones targeting
rainbow reload militia watch this
one of the members Sharon recently
transitioned and I went from concealed
carry every once in a while when I was
sort of feeling it to every single day
because reading the news
having a few experiences realizing that
I've gone from
old
CIS male white upper middle class really
no
no real fears about anything to there
are people that just
looking at me will want to hurt me
there's that individual fear fear of
what may happen simply existing in
public but for some there's also a more
organized and ominous threat including a
Neo-Nazi group now active in New England
that's targeted trans people
the Neo-Nazi group Act Ive in New
England the least right-wing region in
America
every state is blue but there's a
Neo-Nazi group that's terrifying
everybody look just to be clear we're
not against people American citizens
carrying firearms having firearms we
supported including trans people it's
fine but what you're watching here is
not the exercise of the Second Amendment
what you're watching here is political
Hysteria fear ginned up on purpose with
maximum dishonesty in order to get
people in a state of agitation armed
people in a state of agitation doesn't
matter if they're trans or not whatever
that is
it's the same template always
scare the crap out of your voters
tell them that their lives are at risk
encourage them to get guns how do you
think that ends
but by the way if we're following the
logic here and why not that's in short
supply in this country you have to kind
of Wonder like what's the limit to this
so if trans people are in fear for their
lives in every region in the country
including New England which apparently
is crawling with Nazis now
why wouldn't we be arming them as we are
say Ukraine's trans Army and there are
famously trans people in Ukraine's Army
they're very very proud of that
so why stop with the AR-15s I mean why
not
f-35s or tanks you know that's a
question for our highest ranking trans
Admiral
Richard Levine here is Richard Levine in
July of 2020 describing the threat
the most vulnerable Among Us continue to
suffer
including lgbtq individuals of color
lgbtq youth
lgbtq seniors
and lgbtq immigrants
so none of that is factually true as we
just told you in fact some of the people
he's describing are not the most
oppressed in our society but literally
and measurably the most entitled and
privileged the Biden Administration
hired a kid to oversee nuclear waste
disposal whose only qualification was
his sexual fetishes so no there's not
genocide going on there's some weird
affirmative action program going on but
if you listen to NPR you wouldn't know
that and that kind of talk might scare
the heck out of you and if they
encourage you to go get a gun and arm
yourself because Nazis are taking over
Vermont
you might do it
again worse for guns as you could
possibly be but this seems like an
incitement
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight